Now, suppose you have an object of a class that implements the drawable
interface. For example, a house, then you can save it in a variable whose type
is the interface. And that intuitively makes sense, a house, is a kind of
drawable. Now that solves our problem. because similarly, we can make an
ArrayList of drawables, and this ArrayList now can hold dogs, houses, whatever.
You simply take any object of any class that implements the drawable interface,
and you add it to the ArrayList. It works, because you can convert from a dog,
to a drawable which is what this ArrayList holds. In our same class, we can
replace these three ArrayLists with a single one, an ArrayList of drawable. Go
ahead and do that. When you're done, you should have just one ArrayList into
which you add three cars, two houses, and three dogs. And down here, you should
have just one loop. Of course, you also need to make sure that the car, house,
and dog classes all implement the drawable interface.